entire neighborhoods submerged after
heavy rains flooded parts of California
I think I visual on them
nearly 200 people had to be rescued by
First Responders and the National Guard
over the weekend Monterey County
officials issued multiple evacuation
orders last night along the Salinas
River stretching nearly 30 miles
in the city of Pajaro a levee breach
forced thousands of Farm Workers like
Isaac Martinez to evacuate their homes
and likely lose out on work on the
summer I work in the fields picking
berries and uh I think this year is
going to be however it's the waters too
high California grows more than a third
of the country's vegetables and
three-quarters of its fruits and nuts
all threatened by constant flooding this
winter lettuce strawberries the top
crops that are grown in these fields
there's going to be an impact to our
nation's food supply